on a pu on a pu constater qu'en fait que
ces défaites s'étaient déjà produits
dans ce quartier quand je lis bellevue
et que ces jeunes voulaient en découdre
directement avec la police pour empêcher
nous empêchait très clairement de faire
notre travail
voilà vous en avais un peu marre
aujourd'hui d'être prise à partie sur
les sucs en vous allez sur le terrain et
plus être en sécurité
un peu marre c'est ça un bien grand mot
je trouve
on en a pas marre je pense qu'on est
arrivé dans l'excès dans l'excès ou tout
chaque policier je le dis tout le temps
il ya un mondial il ya un manque de
famille un père ou une mère et c'est
donc c'est d'entrer à la maison il ya
constate qu'avec les derniers événements
constatés où il ya un malaise qui s'est
installé en martinique personne ne sait
plus rester à sa place
tout le monde se prend pour je ne sais
quoi et le fonctionnaire de police de
police actuel qui vous parle il tiens à
vous dire tout simplement qu'il est
fatigué fatigué de cette situation
fatigué de la bêtise de la méchanceté
des gens
il reconnaît plus en tant que citoyen
martinique elle reconnaît plus son pays
tout simplement et qu'il ya un malaise
grave dans son pays va falloir tout ce
qu'on s'asseye autour d'une table et
puis qu'on puisse en discuter qu'on
trouve des solutions rapidement pour ce
pays parce que la martinique n'est plus
la martinique